the streaming sphere right now seems
like it's just fun it just
seems like it's you you get more chances
to really collaborate and make friends
as well which is one thing i'm really
jealous about
i don't know if it's because i'm paying
more attention to streaming it just
seems like it's in a really good place
right now
i think it it is it's funny because i
think streaming is in a really good
place i think twitch
is like it's it that we've complained
about youtube
my god twitch as a platform jesus christ
yeah it is almost just from how i
see it it seems like it's almost [ __ ]
impossible to grow on twitch as like
someone who's coming from nothing yeah i
was wait do you guys know
why are all the youtubers on youtube why
is it mostly uh at least japanese ones
why are they on youtube because
youtube i feel oh i mean this is just my
guess but i feel it's because youtube to
a japanese audience is a lot more
well-known than twitches
i feel twitch i mean not to say that
there aren't massive japanese streams on
twitch there are
and yeah some of them pull insane
[ __ ] numbers but
i feel it's just two completely
different worlds like
i don't know this is just my guess but i
feel for a regular japanese
viewer of content online you
stick only to one website and that's it
yeah whereas like
you know i feel it's like if you're a
youtube watcher you are exclusively a
youtube watcher if you're a twitch
watcher you're a twitch watcher if
you're a nico nico watcher
you're only on nico nico whereas i feel
that same mentality doesn't work for
a western viewer right like a western
view will be like well yeah i'm going to
watch some content on youtube i go where
the content is
but yeah but like i can also go on to
twitch if i want to right yeah i guess
so
because maybe yeah i mean for me i'd
hardly watch any twitch
at all on the twitch platform but i
think what's becoming more common now is
like
twitch and youtube are becoming more and
more intertwined
where like a lot of some of the most
popular content and some of the most
original content as well right now has
been
twitch highlights yeah and that's why
i've grown way more of an appreciation
for twitch like i still
spend very little time on the platform
as a as a consumer but i
end up consuming a lot of twitch content
on youtube which is why i think like one
of my favorite content creators right
now is probably ludwig
where he's just doing like the subathon
that he's doing right now is
insane [ __ ] insane definitely over by
now yeah yeah
definitely hopefully it's over by now oh
my god
i was like are you gonna like die on
camera like yeah
is that when the subathon hints sleeping
on camera is like one of the most
bizarre things for me to like think
about doing
let's join george we want to explain
what who ludwig is yeah so
ludwig used to be uh very big in the
smash community
um then moved to streaming and just
became like an instant hit
streaming he's very funny uh very
naturally charismatic he's he's just a
natural-born entertainer
yeah yeah and he did a thing where every
sub
it adds 10 seconds i believe something
like that so every time someone
subscribes to his twitch channel 10
seconds get added and it went up to like
you know 70 hours so so the big
difference is that he made
normally in the subathon you you cap the
number of hours
that you can possibly stream for a time
he made the stream
stream uncapped and i think right now
he's been streaming for over a week
continuously it's like two weeks i think
is it two weeks yeah yeah and then he
just sleeps on stream and that's
something to me that i'm like dude what
if i just like
i like say things in my sleep
[Laughter]
i don't know what you're saying i don't
want to know that's it
i don't say anything bad but what if
it's the one day where i say something
you know that gta clip all the mods of
it where you know they say the thing
about you know what if you go to bed and
then you just say it out loud when
you're sleeping can you be canceled for
being racist in your sleep
i don't know that's that's okay okay
if so if that actually happened would
you be cancelled if someone said
you know they're doing in their sleep
depends if you're a youtuber or not
youtubers are just like that word is
just like free games yeah exactly
everyone every youtuber has that pass
for some reason especially if they're
japanese but
what if you're a white guy ludwig
ludwig's sleeping and then he sleeps
sleep talking and he says that you know
do you get cancelled god there's a part
of me that says
that's ridiculous of course not and then
another part of me is like no he would
definitely get cancelled
i'm gonna be canceled for your dreams
that's like some george orwell well do
you have control over you what does this
say about you
if you say a race call your dream police
if you say a racist thing in your dream
are you racist
wait till it happens it's gonna happen
and no and no one's gonna [ __ ] know
how to deal with it
oh my god i just i'm just imagining like
the plot of inception
everyone sounds like instead of like
putting in an idea you just go in the
dream just to cancel them in the dream
they'll be like i'll be like two camps
they'll be like the camp that believes
like you know okay well he just said in
this video there'll be another
thing like i bet he's secretly awake and
said cause he's racist
nobody says that in this nobody unless
he's awake
she's awake and racist this is a really
weird tangent i just thought like
you know i think it's a very valid
thought experiment though i think it's a
very valuable
i see when i see sleeping through stream
as a content creator i just think like
everything i think it could go wrong
yeah what if i [ __ ] myself in my sleep
everything might be taken out of context
what if i do a rip an
absolute massive fart like the wettest
thing just like any of the stuff that
like could reasonably happen to sleep
that is totally normal
not being racist in your sleep i don't
know if that's normal probably probably
isn't
like you know not that i would know you
know
and like he takes his shirt off when
he's uh when he was sleeping right
and you know what if you just like cause
you know sometimes you [ __ ] throw the
sheets off of someone you're sleeping
yeah i wonder
oh yeah you sleep naked as well don't
you well i also i mean what if i just
like pop a nut on the stream right like
if you get you know you're lying down
you got a morning wood big big boner
yeah
right on stream 4k like what did you get
banned for that like there's just i'm
just literally
the stuff that you would never ever
think would ever happen normally when
you're sleeping
just suddenly become like this is my
number one worry now actually
no it is valid yeah i mean there's a lot
of things you don't control
it you know yeah there's a lot of things
because with youtube we can we could
easily edit stuff
out if we've said something you know but
i just want to say if i if i shat myself
i would own it by the way
i would yeah yeah yeah i mean like i
i feel like the possibly like the worst
thing that could happen on stream when
you're sleeping is that you just utter a
racist word
i'm just thinking yeah if would you
rather would you rather usher a racist
word or sleep or [ __ ] yourself i'd
rather [ __ ] myself
shake yourself on stream that's great
content you're not going to get canceled
if anything you will be immortalized on
the internet as the one dude
think about the amount of [ __ ] farted
himself think about the amount of subs
you'd get for [ __ ] yourselves on
stream
i could just see it you know you say
something racist you end up on fox being
like
liberals are trying to cancel this man
for being racist in his sleep
i'm just imagining what if like a
youtuber [ __ ] themselves on the stream
can you imagine the super chat for that
no it would be like i'm weirdly turned
on 500 bucks
so thanks for that i needed that